we're joined here in the beautiful city
of
by we have
brother have some nice wash
water
sh's favorite City one of the my
favorite cities yeah no doubt always
welcome the Muslim Community here
especially our brothers and sisters in
may Allah bless themen very beautiful
community may Allah bless them and keep
them strong in all of us this is one of
most probably the oldest communities as
well Muslim communities in the UK I
think as well
alhamdulillah that's amazing no we
thought thought we have a quick
discussion with you I know you have a
very very busy schedule um so may maybe
you can um just in this uh little
discussion maybe tell us a little bit
about some of the da activities and some
of the uh the um the lessons that are
going on um in in your mjid in
Germantown um and also here as well
in at the moment in ger there are
numerous lessons in a number of
different Islamic Sciences for example
the Arabic language minina book one
likewise in the
moment I teach that every Saturday we
have the explanation
of is it relates to
jence is
teaching summarize Prudence
by just completed the summary
of that was every Tuesday we have uh on
the
weekends which is an explanation of
collection of by similar to like 40 okay
in addition to you know the Quran
classes alhamdulillah and the classes
for the children and we're here in for a
seminar today
MD because our you know the is about
educating the people so that we can
fulfill the purpose why Allah created us
which is to worship him alone and that
we worship Him correctly in accordance
to the sun of the Prophet
s it's too much politics you're
teaching alhamdulillah alhamdulillah ald
I mean even politics I mean a public
opinion it requires knowledge you know
in order to navigate correctly we have
to speak with knowledge that's why it's
such a profound statement and it's you
know knowledge proceeds speech and
actions you know that's in everything
Subhan Allah everything even in the
worldly sense you know so more so as it
relates to
religion before we act before we say
anything alhamdulillah we should have
knowledge of what we're saying or what
we're doing now absolutely I think I
think um it's um it's more important um
to to seek knowledge and to focus on
knowledge um and the times of trials and
tribulations especially what's happening
in the world today um don't you think
that's that's that's something that
should be emphasized on without Shadow a
doubt I mean if we look to the Quran you
know Allah He commands us to ask who if
we don't have
knowledge ask the people of knowledge
the people of remembrance if you know
not now so knowledge is key you know
because the danger is if we speak with
ignorance we could end up you know
harming ourselves and harming others if
we look in the Hadith when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam spoke about
you know The Disappearance of knowledge
with the death of the scholars he said
you know if Allah does not leave a
scholar on the
earth the people they will take the
ignorant ones as their leaders you know
demagogues playing on the sentiments And
the emotions of the
people you know they will be asked these
ignorant people these demagogues they
will give fataa verdicts you know based
upon ignorance they will go astray and
they will lead others astray and we've
witnessed this I mean what we're going
through now what's taking place in Gaza
may Allah Aid our brothers and sisters
no doubt it's heartbreaking Subhan Allah
some of the images that we see brings a
person to tears we still have to re
respond with knowledge absolutely not
with emotions because emotions thean
will manipulate them and the first Gulf
War alhamdulillah the people of the
Sunnah we refer to who the senior
Scholars and other than them
alhamdulillah the people of theah they
adopted the correct positions right the
they referred to saf they ended up going
to Regions either losing their lives or
you know causing chaos for the um and
instability in the Muslim lands okay um
yeah so I've also noticed um you guys
have um Regular um daas in M um in Dubai
United
and in Kuwait as well um combined with
with with the umra if you can maybe tell
us a little bit about that some of the
motivations for that as well
alhamdulillah again um trying
to practice the way of
the we know that they would make or and
they would also try and seek knowledge
the first
inl to make alhamdulillah no doubt is a
great act of worship we take a group
from the US or sometimes Hajj but in
addition to that we try and benefit from
the mash from the scholars maybe
complete some books at the same time
alhamdulillah so last year we
done the foundations of
the this year we're going to do the the
three fundamental principles about the
questions of the grave alhamdulillah and
the thing about I know some people they
mock because of its size but that's not
any person of knowledge or scholar some
of the scholars said if somebody
traveled to China m you know in order to
study this book it would be a short
distance because of the gems that we
find in there from the foundations and
the fundamentals of that were pinned by
imely when he Tred from Medina all the
way to Egypt for
one and sometimes Subhan Allah something
may be concise but profoundly benefit
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was given the gift of he would utter few
words but they would have a
comprehensive profound meaning some
Scholars know write books about one
Hadith you know which is a
sentence I mean the opposite is also
true right you have people that have
compiled hundreds of books but they
haven't benefited from them or they or
they've read hundreds of books and they
and they have libraries full of the
books but they don't have actually
any Quran just opinions and fil that's
why alhamdulillah it's about what you
know we strive against our souls as it
relates to you know acquiring knowledge
but at the same time you know we we
strive against our souls after that you
know to try and implement it Allah Grant
all success and forgive us for our
shortcomings a mean a mean mean yeah I
mean this is the obviously this the way
of the companions wasn't it to learn um
the Quran bit by bit and then to
implement without sh doubt to benefit
ourselves and also you know those who
are around us in our communities the
best of the people are those most
beneficial to the people but you can
only benefit someone you know with
knowledge with
knowledge I mean just on the Community
point just basically moving it back to
to the states I mean I saw recently uh
you were on the ABC News and and you
know they were talking about you know
some of the community activities um in
in ger toown right is that they have
requirements to get a permit to get
training to report your missing weapons
these life-saving laws that we have
evidence will prevent the next shooting
perhaps the most impactful piece to
reducing gun crimes is involved
community members and faith leaders like
Imam Hassan Abdi with the Germantown
Masjid our faith instructs us to improve
the area for ourselves and our neighbors
whether Muslim or non-muslim the
neighborhood surrounding the Masjid has
been plagued with crime the violence
recently erupted right in front of the
place of worship and we heard a shooting
we run outside the mosque uh we go to
the corner sadly we see somebody you
know was shot and he ended up dying the
Imam is fighting crime by Taking Back
The Block the mosque has purchased
surrounding properties and turned them
into restaurants a convenience store and
a bookstore even an apartment building
the faith leader then made an
unconventional decision we hired private
security it was not the ideal thing to
do but we provided it for the you know
the entire area especially the
businesses and we noticed a change can't
just make sure y was good as a community
if we're invested in our own areas then
I think we're more involved in the
change rather than expecting people to
come from the outside and do it for us
and that's what it's about being a part
of the change maybe maybe obviously the
opportunity here maybe you can elaborate
on that a little bit just for the
benefit alhamdulillah as I said you know
the preparation is in the M like we saw
with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and the companions when the
prophet migrated to Medina one of the
first things that he did you know was to
establish the Masid you know it was a
Center for Learning and a center for
many of the activities of the Muslims
and from the Masid alhamdulillah the
companions they changed the entire world
alhamdulillah it's just short period of
time even the
prophet the best teacher and the best
leader look at the effect that he had on
the Arabian peninsula in such a short
period of time Subhan Allah 23 years Mah
and in Medina 13 you know in Medina for
approximately 10 years Mah you know it
changed the face of the of the
dun so the so the um so maybe tell us a
little bit about like the community
programs um um in in Germantown that
you're um you're act actively par
participating in um it would be be good
for um I guess the people to to to know
about yeah there's a lot of stuff going
on I mean now alhamdulillah you know we
have a full-time school you know next to
the Masid alhamdulillah the Masid they
purchased the building it started in the
Masjid but alhamdulillah after that you
know they purchased the building
adjacent to the Masid what's the
motivation for the school is is that is
that so the the Muslim the Muslim kids
can come into an environment where they
can you know just benefit um from from
an environment that's
Islam without sh doubt I mean the goal
is to have a worldly
education our children they need to be
able to speak correctly likewise you
know learn arithmetic mathematics
alhamdulillah you know to function you
know in this world whether they get a
trade or whether they you know get an
education but at the same time you know
the foundation of that also is you know
an understanding of the religion an
understanding of the religion which will
help them alhamdulillah prosper in the D
because without you know a person
praying Salah what's the benefit of D
without IM what is the benefit of D you
know whether you're a rich person or a
poor person in order to live a happy or
content life you need IM you need Faith
it's like the vers in the
Quran whoever does righteous Deeds
whether they're male or female while
they're a Believer we will give them a
happy life Allah Pro promises a happy
life condition for that is what im and
righteous Deeds no okay that's no that's
the
foundation alhamdulillah so
alhamdulillah we have the school
alhamdulillah uh in addition to the
school you know we've purchased a number
of properties on Germantown Avenue we
have an Islamic Center and bookstore
likewise alhamdulillah we have a a
restaurant that we've purchased
hopefully it be open before Ramadan and
other properties as well yeah is it
should go try
out
restaurant The Blessing alah especially
in America German
Town you doing great job alhamdulillah
you know on the ground our is online
yeah there is online aldah but we focus
on the ground too you know teaching the
people because some people they are
active online but when you switch off
the computer they don't exist anymore
Subhan so aldah
the they're busy online and under
theground alhamdulillah and that's what
we say you know when people talk you
know you can pretend online it's like
Hollywood isn't
everybody has Hollywood in their house
now it's Instagram right before you have
to go to be in a movie you have to go to
Hollywood and be an actor but today it's
social media Tik Tok and other than that
but we tell people you know you know
don't just tell us also show us you know
support you know your statements with
your actions and alhamdulillah you can
come any day and visit us and you know
see what we're doing and how we're
trying to benefit ourselves you know and
the community alhamdulillah and even The
Wider Community as you mentioned you
know the segment on the news they
recognize that in terms of the change
and the efforts that are taking place
you know underground alhamdulillah
because I think I think the the main the
main point just for people just to add a
bit of um you know depth to it is is
because there's the communities there's
a lot of gun violence there's a lot of
other sort of criminal activities um
unfortunately that that are taking place
so so these kind of um community
activities positive community activities
help um deflect that kind of and and you
know busy people with more beneficial
things is it without Shad doubt I mean
Islam has a solution for all of those
problems you know and they problems that
plague many in the cities here you know
you may not have the level of gun
violence that we have you have knife
violence right aldah Islam you know if
you look at the of the preservation of
the religion preservation of Life
preservation of wealth preservation of
the intellect and you know preservation
of progeny and even some mention
preservation of you know honor
alhamdulillah you see Islam addresses
all of these social ills and we're just
trying to implement what we find in the
Quran and the Sunnah you know again you
know to benefit ourselves and to benefit
the the
communities alhamdulillah and have you
seen have you seen a lot of um um
non-muslims accepting Islam as well as a
result of some of these activities
without shadow of a doubt Ramadan we had
like over 300 people you know in our
Masid alone Embrace Islam you know in
Ramadan some days it would be like 10
people or even more
you know we would have entire families
embracing the religion because they
recognize that the religion
alhamdulillah you know to worship Allah
alone without any Partners Islamic
monotheism you know it resonates with
the and they see that the benefit Islam
has on you know our communities you know
and the work that you know alhamdulillah
the Muslims are involved in even we have
you know what's amazing as well Shi you
have some parents they're not Muslims
but they'll bring their children to the
Masid you know I want my child you know
to grow you know to to be a Muslim
because they know alhamdulillah that's a
means by the will of Allah you know to
stay away from all you maybe the gangs
and you know the violence and a lot of
the societal ills drugs which you know
drugs play our communities in the cities
I see even if you have lot of activities
for shab for girls and boys Mah you know
out activities you take them to the wood
and you know to the uh yeah they have
the weekend progam you know they have
trips and stuff like that you know we
need to do more you know because
Beautiful You
like advised you know Muslim minorities
you know while we are here you know the
the goal of the Muslim yes is you know
if they have the ability to do so but
while we are here you know establish
what the community needs come you know
for example schools Mass you know even
maybe youth centers where people can
congregate and the children need
Recreation even in the Sunnah we see
alhamdulillah examples the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam encouraging
lawful Recreation you know
okay racing with a horse and exactly
horse RAC of
course we have this kind of
program sh he sent me some of the videos
with the the young shabab wrestling I
think on Friday attending the class and
just even this you know having a
relationship with the youth is good
because it leaves a door open for
because they think when you go to them
and you try and give them advice they
know that you care of whereas if there's
no relationship or there's no connection
times you try and advise someone and
they take it as an attack yes it's like
your parents you know when when our
parents discipline us maybe some of the
sternest scoldings were from our parents
but we know it's from a place of love
right so we accept it and that's why
alhamdulillah these programs as well
they help us establish those bonds
alhamdulillah like in our Friday we have
a lecture then we have wrestling then we
have food ald a lot of young people come
Mah you know they come from school even
non Muslims coming you there were two
non Muslims came but alhamd they sh
after you know become Muslims yeah yeah
after the the rest and the food mallah
so yeah we doing it every Friday
alhamdulillah no that's one of the the
things that we see alhamdulillah from
the people of the Sunnah like for
example you know people think that shami
maybe he's just at the da table no
alhamdulillah he has regular lessons you
know somebody Embraces Islam what's
after that aldah come to the Masid and
that you know shows the importance of
the project that you guys have you know
purchasing a bigger space because you
know the space that you're at is you
know it doesn't suffice your needs right
yeah this is this is the this is the
opportunity is worth worth mentioning
that you know we uh obviously we are
definitely looking for um and a
different building um and mean as as
people have probably seen from the
different videos that we've that we've
put out there you know the conditions
[Music]
the
Allah
it's not at the moment yeah I Subhan
Allah even though many people ask me I
mean of crazy things but I think
everyone saw it small but alhamdulillah
we have everyday classes Quran classes
alhamdulillah Arabic classes classes
classes as I we have mentioned we have
every Friday lecture then we have
wrestling food alhamdulillah so we try
our best to have our communities
alhamdulillah so we are raising money to
uh we are looking for a place and we are
raising money to purchase a new place
bigger place to help the community and
to because even like our normal classes
there's a lot of people come noral space
sometimes sometimes you have to rent
upstairs which is like a aan community
center we have to rent it for 2 hours
100 but because it's not in our
space outside you know there also safety
for the Sisters as well we we need a
place where they can feel more
comfortable I mean it highlights the the
growth of the yeah all over the
world like you mention Subhan Allah even
like the online in the US we have
thousands of live listeners in addition
to you know the M alhamdulillah being
jam-packed you know we even need to
think in the future to expand we just
have a few projects that we're trying to
take care of firstly but even expanding
in later on ald I was going to say that
just I forgot to mention actually that
those lessons that you they all they all
streamed online or they available online
yeah free we don't charge for any
lessons in the mid alhamdulillah all all
of our lessons are free whether it's
Arabic in the Masjid or you know any of
the Islamic lessons alhamdulillah anyone
can learn and anyone's welcome also I
forgot Subhan Allah likewise on Sundays
there's a sister she teaches the new
Muslim women the new Shas and and
likewise alhamdulillah he does the class
for the new Muslim brothers
alhamdulillah so there's activities for
all levels you know all people
alhamdulillah and like I said looking to
grow and develop and we're open for any
suggestions to improve the community but
again we try and do it on the foundation
which is what you know and you know no
and
no
others you know used to speak about I
was going to I was going to also just
ask about obviously we're talking a lot
about the youth cultivating the youth
and keeping them connected to the Masjid
but also like I mean obviously you know
all the youth and well everyone today
has has has a social media account or or
or multiple social media accounts
Facebook Instagram Snapchat exactly I
mean we we try our best to to you know
limit the time but but obviously with
the youth and the usage or the phone is
is quite um you know it's a bit of a
problem some sometimes but I guess
obviously in these times that we're in
today where there's a lot of um you know
fit now online is's a lot of you know
circulation of maybe doubts and and and
a lot of you know videos and these kind
of things what kind of advice would you
give uh to the to the youth in terms of
um you know using social media in an
intelligent way and in in a way that's
obviously um in line with with the Quran
and Sunnah and you know to prevent them
from issues and things
to social media you know I mean the
internet is a double-edged sword no one
can deny this benefit but also there's a
lot of harm and I think you know over
usage you know even you know many
academics have highlighted the dangers
as it relates to mental illness you know
and other problems that can develop what
I would advise the you know the young
people you know firstly try and you know
learn as much Quran and as much sun as
you can not to say don't use the
internet but don't allow it to divert
you from you know learning the
foundations of your religion you know
learning about allaha the rights of
Allah likewise learning how to pray
correctly how to perform W correctly
learning the basics of the religion and
alhamdulillah you know utilizing the
internet when there's benefit and trying
to stay away from the harms you know
like the scholars advis
F he said you know utilize the internet
and you know social media in order to
promote the truth and to combat
falsehood we have to address some of the
doubts out there we can't you know
address every doubt otherwise that's all
that we will be doing but the scholars
alhamdulillah address the doubts based
upon what they find in the Quran and the
Sunnah how many doubts is Allah refuting
the Quran the doubts you know of
the and other than them so you have to
address the doubts alhamdulillah but we
don't allow it you know to overwhelm us
and divert us from what is going to
benefit us in our worldly Affairs and
more so our religion now yeah even thei
if you look Subhan Allah the prophet
Sall alhi wasallam when he
said
you know strive for what's going to
benefit you that should be the goal
whether it's in the worldly sense or you
know again you know at ahead of that the
religious sense seek the aid of Allah
don't be lazy yeah you know because I
mean I guess you know people just um you
know just just scrolling through hours
and hours and just maybe retweeting
something they they feel emotionally
connected to might not necessar
necessarily be the right thing to do in
C certain circumstances without Shadow
doubt I mean you look at it sometimes
you may spend hours just looking at
something you start looking at one post
and you you you've wasted you know how
many hours those hours whether you know
you're in education you could have maybe
wrote a whole thesis or even as it
relates to religion how many ay from the
Quran you
memorize even has a nice advice he said
even if you have to use social media one
advice don't use it too much also try to
not look at it before you go to sleep
cuz what it does affect you mentally if
you go to look at something which is
negative and you're going to sleep it's
going to affect you like some people
especially now again may Allah help our
brother and sister Allah Allah give them
victory over the enemies people sending
videos and the pictures of
children and people look look fleeking
through it at night before you go to
sleep it's not good for you mentally you
know Subhan Allah so also Subhan Allah
one of the the bad side of social media
is is making it easy for for uh Brothers
and sisters to free mix you know talking
to each other and you know subh Allah
you have to remember Allah's watching us
you know I think I think the the effects
of I think the evil effects of
normalization of horrific things is is
has a bad effect because then you think
that's you I've seen that now I'm
accustomed to it it's it's become num
doesn't become shocking when you see it
so I mean that's why you know even if we
look alhamdulillah in the Sunnah a
person should wake up with what
remance of Allah when you go to sleep
you should be going to sleep without you
know and that's why when the prophet s
was was asked you know about what is the
the best wealth you know we know what
has being revealed about gold and silver
it comes in the they asked the
prophet what's the best wealth he said
what he said a tongue that remembers
Allah a heart that thanks Allah and the
wife a believing wife that aids the
husband upon his faith you know Subhan
Allah and you know that right there is
just so precious a tongue that remembers
Allah if a person's tongue is moist with
the remembrance of
Allah the heart will be content you know
you will avoid a lot of the The
Forbidden things as it relates to the
tongue right a heart that's grateful and
thanks Allah you'll be content with
regardless of the predicament you're in
and a believing wife you know and also
or a believing husband that's going to
Aid somebody in the IM because the goal
is what this is temporary this world you
know the goal is Paradise Allah bless
all of the Muslims in paradise and
Subhan Allah I was listening to this
psychologist and he was saying that one
of the mistakes people do when they wake
up in the morning again they start
looking today Instagram or Snapchats he
said instead wake up in the morning of
he's a Hindu may Allah guide him but he
said what I do I do my prayer of course
it's B but Subhan Allah I was speaking
that's what Adis us with the first as we
when you wake up Al what you do
pray then before you go
sleep even they used to say
about mentions you know he would sit
after isn't it and he would make his and
you know he would say this is basically
this is my breakfast you know this is my
nourishment my nutrition spiritual food
because and the other example he said
the remembrance of Allah tala he said
the relationship between that and the
heart is like the relation between fish
and water you know if you take the Fish
Out of Water the fish will die if you
take you know remebrance of Allah away
from the heart the heart is going to die
and that's why you know when we look
around this in society you know
sometimes we're amazed that people's
behavior is because of the distance and
the remoteness from the remembrance of
Allah it's a simple things isn't it when
when you go back Basics it's the basics
it's the basics it's not too complicated
it's just it's just the basics
yeah whoever turns away from remembrance
you will have a miserable life like like
Subhan Allah in the western world
everything is easy the dun like
literally you can be sitting at home you
can get your food your clothes
everything but still people are
depressed Subhan Allah depression is
very high Subhan Allah why because the
true happiness is in the remembrance of
Allah you know what the mentioned as you
know that he said anyone doesn't not
enter to the into the jna of this dun
will never enter to the jna of the
Hereafter when you would ask what is the
jna of this dun
and make us from
the you have to take pleasure in in in
the remembrance of Allah and in the but
the only way I think you can do that is
if you focus what was the name was actor
recently that Subhan Allah they found
him dead right yeah yeah you know very
successful in the worldly sense famous
very rich used to get paid 1 million an
episode yeah 1 million episode
for it highlights what you know you know
a person can have money but if you don't
have Iman you know there's no enjoyment
it's like you know in life you know and
this is for the young people Allah May
bless you you know with wealth however
if you lose your sanity you know you for
example because of your Disobedience to
Allah or because of the usage of drugs
you end up with you know mental problems
you know that basically because of your
behavior you can't even enjoy the money
that that you acquire so again like I
said whether you're rich or whether
you're poor you know you need IM that's
the foundation and then alhamdulillah if
Allah gives you from this world
alhamdulillah but you're content with
whatever you have content I was going to
ask you briefly well I know we limited
on time but um you know obviously you
mentioned um briefly about with regard
to a lot of non-muslims accepting Islam
both at German Town obviously mentioned
as well regularly we see in the da
tables uh Subhan um I mean just just a
brief advice what would you would you
advice for some of the the recent
reverts to Islam with regards to you
know studying the Quran because
obviously most of them I would imagine
do not understand the Arabic language or
or maybe they're just beginning to learn
how to how to read the Arabic language
and you know they're relying a lot on on
translations and things and then and
then they they're kind of you know H
Hamed with with doubts on about certain
verses that are maybe Mis misused by
some of the enemies of Islam or
interpreted like the AY inah Etc you
know many of these kind of things what
what would you advise them how to you
know navigate these kind of issues
successfully I think that it's important
that you know Islam alhamdulillah makes
a person a better human being you know
more compassionate look at the Hadith
about the person that went to Paradise
because he gave a dog water to
drink so Islam makes a person a better
human being how do we become a better
human being no doubt there are certain
you know mannerisms and qualities a
person may have them innately Allah has
you blessed them with them a person may
be generous but there are certain things
maybe you need to work on how do you do
that you know you learn correctly how do
we learn correctly we make sure we learn
from the right sources we learn from the
Quran and the Sunnah and we take from
who the teachings of the scholars of
this um especially the senior Scholars
so I would say you know advising new
Muslims yes alhamdulillah it's important
that we learn but also learn what learn
Quran and Sunnah and learn from where
the senior Scholars the senior Scholars
of this time alhamdulillah you know
according to the people of knowledge and
the scholars of Islam the likes
of and other than them and alhamdulillah
and then you have their students and you
have in the west alhamdulillah people
who have graduated from the Islamic
universities or study with these
Scholars alhamdulillah who are teaching
exactly the same things as these
Scholars so you know find The M whether
you're in London alhamdulillah whether
you're in Birmingham
alhamdulillah whether you're in you know
or other communities you have aldah
where people are teaching how we worship
Allah correctly without any Partners
staying away from sh we're teaching the
three fundamental principles how to
respond to the questions of the Grave if
you respond to them correctly you're
guaranteed Paradise likewise how to pray
correctly how to make W
correctly you know the Islamic conduct
and character and other than that you
know these alhamdulillah these are
things that should be focused upon yes
yeah I think also probably it's
important to to that you know when they
reading the the verses um should they
refer to like or like different aspects
of the S just to better understand some
of the contextual yeah if you learn
that's how I said you know if you learn
for example the Arabic language
alhamdulillah you have access to the
classic you know before him they
call you know you learn the Arabic
language alhamdulillah you learn from
the scholars of the Sunnah you'll have
access to you know the scholars of the
Sunnah even those who have passed away
you know through their works and through
their books you
know if something is problematic for us
aldah we still have Scholars that are
living today the people of misguidance
and deviation they will say that you
know like we find on the internet now
you know you can't trust the scholars or
you know if anyone teaches in a
university or receives a government
salary you know they can't be trusted
which is very dangerous
because Yousef had a position in an un
Islamic government but obviously he
judged based upon the revelation from
Allah subhana wa tala right and he
judged with that which was correct so
the danger is for example with that type
of message okay we have the book but
who's going to explain to us if we
misunderstand something the people of
deviation and misguidance they want to
get rid of the scholars alhamdulillah
the people of the Sunnah recognized what
the prophet Sall alhi wasallam he
said the scholars you know the real true
Scholars the inheritors of the prophets
no and working for the government
doesn't make you agent of the I
with and there's many of the past judges
I mean how many even with the companion
Subhan Allah they had position from the
you know at the time of abak
alhamdulillah the time of the time of
the time of Ali alhamdulillah there were
companions who had positions as judges
and teachers and other than that and
from what's the problem the issue is
like he clarified the issue is when a
person you know justifies falsehood
because of their position now that's a
that's problematic and we say to them
you know those who claim that the
scholars of the Sunnah are agents they
will have to answer for that we fear for
them the of the
Prophet
said whoever harms one of my oah my
allies I've announced war against them
we fear for them that had but you know
the thing about it these Scholars bring
to us where they've Justified music
festivals you will not bring one
statement bring to us where they they
condemned you know the the call of unity
of religions they said it's you will not
find a scol we challenge them bring us
one fat of any of the scholars of the
Sunnah where they have Justified or
agreed with any evil you will never find
one the scholars recognize evil as being
evil but if it is present in some of the
Muslim lands they believe that there is
a way of advising the Muslim rulers
without undermining them and again we
spoke about politics right these people
they you know politics and they want to
busy the um with politics based upon
ignorance has an explanation
of right and he mentions in there the
without undermining the rulers and
causing instability and bloodshed in the
Muslim lands that's the issue so look at
the you know the slander and the lies of
the people of FAL if you have truth you
don't have to lie against anyone by
Allah you know we do not lie against the
non-muslims so what about the Muslim
that we disagree with these some of
these individuals they lie and they will
call you for example they say the of the
the Jews of the or they will say a
government agent or they will twist your
words or make a St man argument just to
disparage a person that they disagree
withd the people of
the
said the most knowledgeable of the
people about the truth and the most
merciful of the people to the people
because alhamdulillah the truth you
don't have to lie with the truth and
that's a sign of the people of used to
say you can recognize F because all they
resort to is lies like for example the
post
when mentioned that he's going to be at
the da table in look at the LI subh
Allah in the comments that's enough to
show you that these individuals are upon
for may Allah protect his I me now
nowadays any even if you're making a
right statement it can be cut up and
then
Ed it's not you you could be saying
something correct and and and and then
it's could be you know misused yeah
people can cut out and and Subhan Allah
even working for a Muslim government and
Allah he told
us so if you're working with the Muslim
government with that which will benefit
the Muslim um something which is a
praiseworthy you know subh so we have
examples like we said
with refuting those who try to say that
uh those who works for the government
Islamic government uh can be trusted or
try to undermine the schoolers are
working for the government can ref them
and has commentary upon that of a and
that's the thing knowledge you know not
just you know learning your religion
from a tweet or Instagram post you know
individuals that have dubious
backgrounds you know they call for
example people boot lickers or agents
anyone can do that you know they
say is what you know a person that is
bankrupt doesn't have any any valid
points they abuse people and they you
know they slander and they they can
insult the any child can insult you know
you go to the playground you have you
know some young children you know when
they have a confrontation they may
resort to an insult anyone can do that
but when it comes to for example a
matter of the religion Allah said the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
the companion said and it's based upon
what it's based upon truth not emotions
no like one of the he said you don't
need a qualification from Oxford
University to learn how to insult you
know can do it have to you don't need
qualification Subhan Allah but you know
subh I was speaking to one of our
brothers he says what's happening now as
if some Muslim have no because
Allah whatever you going to Allah will
ask you about it I mean the edge will
write down and I will ask you to accuse
a brother that is working for the
Zionist subh if someone was working for
the zence against the Muslims
that's are you really to stand before
Allah to say Allah yes I'm sure but we
have to
understand accusations you know they're
not new like some of the they
said a sign a clear sign one of the most
obvious signs of the people of
innovation you know they abuse and they
attack you know the people of a meaning
the people of Sunnah the people who
follow the way of the and again these
insults are not new they used to say
about that he an agent they used to say
about they used to say the same thing
about they said the same thing about the
scholars of the Sunnah so this is not
going to stop you know when the prophet
sallallah wasallam received Revelation
and he went
to what did he say said before the
prophet came out publicly with the
message he said no one came with what
you came with except except they were so
when you call people to there's going to
be harm because you're warning is sh
right when you call people to sunah and
you're warning is there's going to be
harm yeah when you're going against the
agenda of for example various movements
there's going to be harm you have people
on social media now defending the right
to work with the ra the sh but
condemning for example Saudi Arabia look
at the agenda behind this is deeper what
meets the eye with some of these
people I mean sorry I was just I was
just going to say it because because
what the way I look at it is like in the
end are you actually benefiting the
people that you claim to want to benefit
like the obviously the people of
Palestine and are you actually
benefiting the general
Muslims you mentioned this I want to
mention the
statement he has a beautiful speech
concerning the oppression that was
taking place during his lifetime theik
you Brothers claiming that you are there
to support Philistine by your lying and
slandering people and as oppression so
how you is going to accept be accept by
Allah if you are oppressing the
Muslims when he was asked how come Allah
is not answering the Dua of those who
have been oppressed by the government
during his lifetime he said because the
people themselves they oppress each
other know
said fear the supplication of those who
have been oppressed because there is
nothing between the the person's Dua and
for Allah to accept it but what Allah
accepted the
Dua said because the people are
oppressed too and those who have those
who are not oppressing no one they're
not leaving out of Oppression out of
fear of Allah they're leaving it out
because they cannot do it Subhan Allah
so Subhan Allah you claiming you want to
support our brother but you have no
Allah to lie slunder
and you complain to Allah alhamdulillah
you know the solution for all of the
global problems the prophet s wasallam
highlighted you know used to quote it
lot he has actually actually a whole
lesson on it and they translated a book
in English I think based on the when he
said you know that will place upon you a
[Music]
humiliation you know Allah will not
remove the humiliation until you return
back to the religion said the prophet s
wasam he gave us the he gave us you know
that's the cure to the predicament that
we find ourselves in no doubt
alhamdulillah it Grieves every Muslim
what's taking place in in Palestine this
is clear oppression
I think more than 9,000 people have been
killed and this is from what October the
7th and this October what now November
sorry from from yeah October when did it
start October 7 now nov mon near a month
and and more than 9,000 people have been
killed just mention there's a video on
when I was speaking to one of the
brothers on Tik Tok and I got very upset
Subhan Allah uh what's happened to our
brother and S festine and what guy moed
me said sh is a therapy I mean don't thy
aldah because we pray to Allah of course
what's happening to my brother and
sister is affecting me is literally
affecting me that I see brother and
sister are dying thousands of our
brother dying and you to fil me so
you're moing me for for getting angry
for this for seeing our brother and
sisters children die then you know we're
going to stand before Allah but subh
like you
mentioned I want to mention because
they but living of yeah but
said the
other until you check your is our
correct know to
say alhamdulillah you know the scholars
are the head of the um and with regards
to the sacrifice and their efforts you
know many of the scholars Subhan Allah
you know they went to Afghanistan you
know and other than him alhamdulillah
you know they're not just armchair
instigators like you find some of these
people in the west you know as the they
said the worst type of the are the
armchair instigators you know and that's
what happened after 911 you have people
they're sitting in their houses in the
west sending Muslim children to be you
know to be massacred and slaughtered in
Syria and other places while they enjoy
the Comforts of their
but the scholars alhamdulillah you know
the scholars they're going to judge
Affairs based upon what's taking place
but they're going to analyze it in light
of the Quran and the Sunnah and they're
not going to give verdicts based upon
emotion alhamdulillah the um will
benefit from their direction that like
alhamdulillah look the prophet
sallallahu alai wasam even the Treaty of
Al and I don't want to go into too much
depth because this is
my no I don't want to goo much dep but
you know the companion Subhan Allah they
expected that they were going to go to
the Kaa that year and because of the
Treaty of hudia they wasn't allowed at
that time likewise the agreement that if
any of the Muslims were to flee from
Mecca and go to Medina they were to be
they were to be handed back to the mus
of Mecca this was Heavy upon you know
some of the Companions and there's a
narration Inari you know one of the
companions he said after that he said he
said beware beware and suspect opinions
meaning based upon emotions he said
because at that day he said if I was to
if I was able I had the power to reject
the command of the messenger of Allah I
would have done so Subhan Allah look
showing the danger of emotions when
they're not anchored by the Quran and
the Sunnah we're going to have emotions
we're going to have emotions we're going
to be upset Subhan Allah you look at
some of the things the the scenes we're
seeing like I said Subhan Allah we're
adults and you know it brings a person
to tears you know and you become but the
same time look what did the prophet he
said the judge should not give a
judgment if he
has a
chapter about not giving a judgment or
the MU not giving a f while they're
upset why because that emotion could
lead you to out of falsehood because
you're not looking at the text of theab
and the is based upon your emotions so
that's the important thing yes we're
going to have emotions we're human
beings but those emotions it is a must
that anchored according to the Quran and
the Sunnah who are the ones
alhamdulillah who are most able to do
that the scholars who have gone gray
with their knowledge and their
experience and their wisdom in defense
of the Quran and the Sunnah and you know
these are individuals alhamdulillah the
scholars they will be the ones to direct
the um to correct change and that's what
we find in the Quran not influences yeah
go back to influences or for example you
know you say you take a vote ask the
people like had for example discussion
with one individual and he says what do
you say so Subhan Allah now you believe
in voting that that's the correct you
know stance not in what is in the Quran
and the Sunnah Subhan Allah the ones
look
after he was killed and was that door
when it was broken erupted may Allah
protect the Muslims and it hasn't been
closed since
then look at the ignorant people that
that they were able the you know the the
people of f were able to gather you know
to rebel against and killed
him it was because of emotions emotions
yeah and ring up the people and Tak away
from the sah exactly yeahh Allah clearly
said so Allah mentioned clearly that and
mention this verse Allah said if aair of
fear or security comes to them instead
of spreading it they should refer it
back to Allah's messenger and to the
scholars and the leaders not of people L
Muslims because this matter is a serious
matter it's for the scholars and not for
any scholar for major Scholars and the
leaders to sit down and discuss the
issue not one scholar come out and start
giving his opinion Subhan Allah so and
and this verse clear clearly in the
Quran but the individual Subhan Allah he
had no problem to oppose the verse and
to choose a democracy over
the all right I think for for the
beneficial discussion and you know
obviously he's gone full circle back to
uh back to knowledge so everything goes
back to knowledge I think so for your
time and I know you've got a very
important talk um today as well which
we'll be putting out as well
recording I mean just to close remember
as well one of the I mean knowledge
Subhan Allah knowledge benefits you in
this world but also even in the grave
you know knowledge is one of those
things yes knowledge alhamdulillah is
more precious than wealth because you
know when you act upon your knowledge
alhamdulillah inshallah Allah will
increase you in your knowledge you know
when you spend your wealth you know it
decreases from your wealth knowledge
also you know it safeguards you whereas
you have to try and protect and
Safeguard your world but even in the
grave the prophet he told us one of the
things that will benefit the individual
is knowledge that the people they
benefit from and that's why you know
some of they said that the scholars even
though they're dead it's like they're
still alive meaning we benefit from
their books you know so may Allah you
know benefit us with beneficial
knowledge and one of that's the
application after you know the prophet
he would make
the Allah I ask you for beneficial
knowledge and lawful sustenance and
actions that are
accepted